[Music]
on this saturday night a humanitarian
ceasefire declared and broken
a halton fighting to allow ukrainians to
leave the country ends abruptly
stranding thousands without food water
or heat
a desperate plea for help while vladimir
putin renews a threat and the u.s warns
its citizens to leave russia immediately
exodus from war
and the terrifying reality for those who
stay behind and a canadian city with
deep ukrainian roots rallies to help
friends and family a world away glory to
ukraine
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us at
the first ceasefire attempted in ukraine
to evacuate civilians collapsed not long
after it began ukrainian officials
accuse russia of breaking the partial
truce efforts to allow more than 200 000
people to escape the fighting have
halted residents forced to turn back aid
agencies warned the humanitarian crisis
will grow more dire as food water and
medical supplies run short david aiken
has our top story
the ukrainian city of mariopol a
strategic port on the sea of azov has
been surrounded by russian troops for
days many of its 450 thousand residents
without water electricity or heat as
bombs and shells rained down
civilians desperately sought shelter
there had been hope at least half of
those residents might have been allowed
to leave under a russian proposed
ceasefire that guaranteed a humanitarian
corridor but it was not to be as
ukrainian said the russians continued
the shelling
water and heat this doctor says we have
some issues with supplies we worked more
than a week without a break
municipal officials say the city may run
out of food
we don't have food supplies says this
woman people are taking everything shops
are empty the weakness of everything
that's happening is that we're relying
on the good faith of the russians which
we can't do they've just invaded
in what we i think there's many many
many uh much evidence of criminal
activity
in a village north of kiev yulia yanchar
is looking for a way that she and her
daughter can leave yeah
her daughter is defiant we will not be
scared of anything
and
i am six years old
slava okay
at the train station in kiev igor
kirienko sends his son and family to the
west
and to safety
while he promises to stay
the black sea port city of kirsan was
captured by the russians but thousands
crowded the city square there saturday
to protest
as video emerged of russian military
vehicles destroyed in the fight for
kirshan the russian army is not
unbeatable putin is not unbeatable
in this context it's only all
he has the vetoes that we allow him to
have and if we say no you don't have a
veto
then
we we can
push back
but by the end of the weekend
authorities believe 1.5 million people
will have left ukraine fleeing putin's
army
david aiken global news
russian president vladimir putin warned
today any third party declaration of a
no-fly zone over ukraine would be seen
as participation in the war it came as
ukraine's president begged u.s lawmakers
to push nato into action and asked for
more humanitarian aid as the refugee
crisis worsens jennifer johnson has the
latest ukraine president volodimer
zielinski had a zoom call with more than
300 u.s lawmakers pleading for help in
getting nato to declare a no-fly zone
over ukraine nato is refusing saying it
could lead to a full-fledged war in
europe
on saturday russia president vladimir
putin warned that could be seen by
moscow as a step into the military
conflict nato is also refusing to supply
ukraine with fighter jets lawmakers
promised to push u.s president joe biden
to make that happen there are planes
available by nato nations migs that the
ukrainians can fly
they're waiting to be delivered and
apparently the united states
is part of the problem not the solution
zielinski is also asking the u.s to stop
buying russian oil which amounts to
about three to four percent of american
consumption guys like putin they don't
stop
and we got to recognize that the white
house and congress are now pledging
another 10 billion dollars in
humanitarian aid as ukrainians leave
their homeland more than 700 thousand
people have been forced to flee the
violence perpetrated by russia by
crossing the border from ukraine to
poland
secretary of state lincoln visited a
refugee center in poland as that
country's leaders warned putin there
will be consequences for his actions
shelling residential areas
nuclear power plants are war crimes
under international law
which are not subjected to statue of
limitation the u.s state department and
the canadian government are now advising
citizens to leave russia immediately
this came as news emerged that russia
arrested wnba star brittany griner last
month charging her with drug smuggling
for allegedly having vape cartridges
containing hashish oil in her carry-on
luggage this video reportedly showing
the search was released by russia
customs service the problem is that
there is no reliable independent
judiciary in russia
so consequently the expectation of a
fair trial is not there greiner plays
for a russian team during the wnba
off-season if convicted she could spend
up to 10 years in prison her agent says
they are working on getting her back to
the u.s
jennifer johnson global news washington
with the growing challenges to get into
ukraine our teams have been reporting
from neighboring countries for more than
a week covering the unprecedented
refugee situation but today a first-hand
look at the situation on the ground in
la vie mike armstrong takes us through
the journey to enter a now war-torn
country
this country is under a national curfew
here in la viv it's effective as of 10
pm at night local time you're no longer
allowed on the streets and you're not
supposed to show any light through your
windows
our small team and large amount of gear
left the city in poland where we've been
staying at about 9 30 this morning the
trip to the medica crossing was clear
sailing and then you hit the line now as
vehicles wait to get to the border
you're passed over and over by empty
buses they're picking up refugees who
are on foot and taking them to refugee
processing centers ukraine is running 27
right now there's one very close to the
medicare crossing
now leaving poland you go through their
border and then entering ukraine you go
through theirs considering it meant
entering a country that's literally
fighting a war was actually quite easy
then came this moment when we pulled out
of the border facility and saw thousands
of people waiting on foot to get through
there were audible gasps from our team
moving from there the shock came from
the lineup of vehicles we were driving
against car after car bus after bus this
line stretched for about four kilometers
people sat engines off and waited the
crossing into medica poland is the
busiest of any border being used by
ukrainians to go to any neighboring
country in fact according to the numbers
put out by the ukrainian border guard
it's actually twice as busy as the
crossing in second place
from the border and into the town of
levive we passed or were stopped at
about a dozen checkpoints people were
still building them fortifying them now
arriving in la viv it felt quite normal
there was fairly heavy traffic things
seemed to be somewhat busy
but then at about 9 00 p.m local time an
air raid siren everyone in our hotel was
told to go to the basement that lasted
about a half hour but it's something
people here are getting used to it's
been happening fairly regularly in this
area despite the fighting not really
happening in this part of western
ukraine
the curfew that is in place
stays in place until 6 am
mike armstrong global news la viv
ukraine
the canadian ambassador to ukraine is in
poland witnessing the flood of refugees
arriving every day eric sorenson spoke
with her on the west block about the
determination and grief ukrainians are
experiencing eric
colleen out of the destruction in
ukraine hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians have emerged families with
their children seeking refuge they are
arriving in romania hungary slovakia
many countries but most some eight
hundred thousand now have come to poland
canada is preparing to take in
ukrainians an unlimited number
temporarily with immigration rules being
eased to make it happen quickly canada's
ambassador to ukraine larissa galadza is
in poland she has been struck by the
effort of the people needing help and
those who are there to help as she told
us on the west block there's a stoicism
and this this hardness of about this
determination in in getting that done
um and then they have their and then
they have their moments uh of of of deep
grief and sadness and and pain they're
being strong for their children and
they're being strong for their uh for
their their colleagues in ukraine and
for the moment that means that
ukrainians inside ukraine uh need to put
up the fight uh the fight of their lives
the russians have suggested that western
countries will eventually accept
ukraine's defeat and will move on
galadza says the russians are misjudging
the resolve of the ukrainians and the
west it's not the first miscalculation i
think that russia has made
and the response that we're seeing from
our like-minded governments the response
we're seeing from ukrainians themselves
is unprecedented canada nato and other
countries are helping on two fronts
delivering weapons and supplies to
defend those trying to survive inside
ukraine and beginning the humanitarian
mission to welcome ukrainians who've
left and who want to come to this
country
colleen
eric sorensen thank you and eric is in
for mercedes-stevenson tomorrow hosting
the west block and you can catch the
full interview sunday right here on
global
for the second straight weekend
protesters in several major cities took
to the streets in solidarity with the
ukrainian people
several thousand gathered in paris
waving ukrainian flags opposing the
russian invasion in london protesters
draped in blue and yellow flooded
trafalgar square and joined in the
singing of the ukrainian national anthem
and this was the scene outside the
russian embassy in the hague hundreds
chanting for an end to the russian
offensive among them a large contingency
of russians who say vladimir putin does
not represent them
in the u.s capitol the national guard
and state police are on high alert
bracing for canada-style convoy protests
[Music]
[Applause]
american truckers from at least three
different convoy groups are making their
way to washington to protest covet 19
mandates and restrictions the so-called
freedom convoy follows demonstrations
that erupted in canada in late january
where protesters blocked u.s border
crossings in ottawa's downtown core for
three
weeks coming up the latvian president's
perspective on putin and nato's response
to the war
as the war in ukraine intensifies one
person who understands what refugees are
going through is vira vic freyberga
latvia's first female president she
spent 50 years in exile after fleeing
with her parents when soviet forces
invaded during world war ii mercedes
stephenson is in the latvian capital and
spoke with vic freyberga about that
experience the russian president and
whether nato will push back mercedes
vira vic freiburger's family fled latvia
when she was just a small child after
the ussr invaded this country by 1954
they had made their way to canada where
she would stay becoming a psychologist
but in 1998 she moved back here to
latvia and just one year later she
became the country's president
freedom and democracy are issues that
are close to the former latvian
president's heart and she speaks to them
often and passionately
after the former president's family
suffered terribly under authoritarianism
she has long warned about the threat of
vladimir putin's regime in russia today
she shared her analysis as a clinical
psychologist on putin's state of mind
which she believes played a role in his
decision to go to war and her belief
that he has underestimated nato he's a
narcissist
a psychopath
with no conscience whatsoever
and
he's an agolo maniac i think he's become
i'd say notably unhinged
in recent times i think this invasion
is not the actions of a sane man
interested in the welfare of his
so i do i do think he really is
getting unhinged now
before he was only evil and mean now
he's also evil mean and unhinged it's a
bad combination
vic freiburger says the most important
thing the west can do right now to
starve vladimir putin's war efforts is
to stop buying russian oil and gas which
she says forms the war chest for the
russian leader to continue to fight she
also raised concerns about the
elimination of the free press in russia
saying it will become an intellectual
prison for the russian people sitting
down with the former latvian president
is another reminder of the close ties
between canada and latvia a country
where canada currently has 540 soldiers
stationed with more on the way
colleen
mercedes stephenson in latvia thanks
mercedes
still ahead why cryptocurrency has
become a double-edged sword in the
russia ukraine war
cryptocurrency has emerged as a key
factor in the war in ukraine experts say
it's likely to support citizens on both
sides of the conflict as people take
their money out of the traditional
economy and move it into global digital
currency but as an gabiola reports it's
unlikely to help russia skirt economic
sanctions
the war in ukraine comes with a horrific
toll on the people involved emotional
and financial russia is spending an
estimated 20 million dollars a day to
continue the invasion the ukrainian
government hasn't put a price on its
defenses but it's issued war bonds to
raise funds while also turning to less
conventional methods on saturday
ukraine's vice prime minister tweeted a
request for donations in the world's
largest cryptocurrencies more than 69
million dollars poured in from around
the world for the ukrainian government
and ngos this is actually a pretty good
solution because it is something that
the russians cannot steal
finance professor andreas park says even
if russia gains control of ukrainian
banks crypto remains safe
but unreliable internet complicates
things with a need for access to move
sell and use the digital currency
elon musk has activated his company's
satellite internet service in ukraine in
a bid to help crypto is also being sent
to russian citizens in the midst of a
spiraling recession unable to use credit
cards and with limited access to cash
this is a tool that's going to be used
for things you support things that you
may be against but that the technology
itself is politically neutral
but that neutrality means authorities
are on alert as vladimir putin and
russian oligarchs may turn to crypto to
lessen the blow of sanctions but
blockchain experts say bitcoin isn't
liquid enough or deep enough to make a
sizeable dent
but if we're looking at the order of
magnitude that you need in order to
meaningfully circumvent sanctions the
cryptocurrency world is just not ready
for that and it's traceable
cryptocurrency has emerged as a
technological double-edged sword with
the potential to help a movement that's
captured the zeitgeist outweighing its
potential to limit sanctions ann gaviola
global news toronto
italian police have seized villas and
yachts belonging to four high-profile
russians who've been placed on an eu
sanctions list one of the people on that
list is alexi mordechov russia's richest
man his 34 million dollar yacht was
impounded in imperia earlier this week
germany and france seized more yachts
additional assets are expected to be
seized in the coming days as further
sanctions from western countries are
implemented against russia
why one canadian town may be feeling the
pain of the war on ukraine more than any
other next
alberta has deep historical and human
connections to ukraine and that's
especially evident in vegaville east of
edmonton it's a town built on ukrainian
routes and the war half a world away is
being met with despair as dan grumman
reports residents are trying to help in
whatever way they can
from the largest pasenka to the smallest
matrushka so much here is distinctly
ukrainian you're actually bringing these
in from the ukraine yeah buying them
from the families there to help support
the minnesota well it supports the meow
greg kurlux sells mostly ukrainian-made
goods the only inspired products he
carries have been taken off the shelf
put away in boxes that's going to hurt
some artists
in ukraine it's not going to
unfortunately not hurt putin
but that's the only thing i can do the
ukrainian-made dolls are still for sale
kerlik's been thinking about the woman
who makes them who lives on the
outskirts of kiev i haven't been able to
contact her i have no idea
sorry
but anyways i mean it's it's a disaster
pain
despair
hope pride there's a range of emotions
being felt by people in this community
impacted by a situation they cannot
control what's it like watching what's
happening
it's horrific ukrainians first came to
the vagaville area 130 years ago lured
by affordable land first generation
ukrainian canadian natalia torreschenko
has lived here 40 years she says a
heaviness has come over the town
it's pretty hard to live in vagaville
and
ignore the ukrainian-ness of it
and so i mean i think it affects all of
us the 2016 census shows just over a
third of vagraville's population is of
ukrainian descent svetlana federuk is
one of them
we can't really sleep much federick is
originally from snatin in western
ukraine her sister is there and won't
leave i'm begging her to come but she's
scared to lose house every morning we
have to just find out if they still
alive that's the worst thing for all the
fear and uncertainty the support here is
more evident
stories of determination emerging from
ukraine have also resonated president
i've had a couple of calls and a couple
of text messages they'd like to rename
this park after the president of ukraine
yeah zelensky park i'm awfully glad that
my great grandfather
chose to to come sold out of flags
kuroluk has ordered more t-shirts
helping others show support is his way
of showing support a way to cope with
what everyone's feeling inside
pray for peace you know slavo karina you
know that
glory to ukraine
dan grumman global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm colleen christie
tonight we leave you with a special
moment of solace on the polish border
[Music]
ukrainian refugees fleeing war are
finding hope through music italian david
martello is there playing for peace
known as piano man martello traveled
from germany with his instrument on
wheels he greeted the stream of women
and children frightened and exhausted
after leaving behind sons and fathers to
try to bring some musical joy to their
lives
he played imagined by john lennon and
was joined on the case by a ukrainian
woman who chose to play queens we are
the champions
thanks for watching
[Music]
you